here is Republican New Hampshire
Governor Chris sununu taken it to Chuck
Todd on just that why are you supporting
an election denialist and and do you
think the inflate inflation issue is
enough
uh to comp to sort of rationalize
support for somebody who thinks
school buses of Voters are going to show
up in New Hampshire
yeah
yeah let me tell you you're in a bubble
man I love you Chuck but you are in a
bubble if you think anybody is talking
about what happened in 2020 or talking
about Mar-A-Lago and all that I know the
Press loves to talk about it people are
talking about what is happening in their
pocketbooks every single day look I get
when they have to buy groceries or right
now
okay how could they
of course oh my gosh Chuck this is
hitting people they're having trouble
paying their mortgage they're having
trouble making car payments because of
bad policies out of Washington should
they be that is look the beauty of the
American system is every voter has the
right and almost the responsibility to
be selfish with their vote to vote in
terms of what is best for their family
the better choice for schools better
Economic Opportunity and that's exactly
what's going to happen in a week which
is why Hassan's going to get fired a
whole bunch of these Democrats are going
to get fired because frankly folks that
think that we're that the average voter
is worried about 2020 the average voter
it's a serious issue of course but it is
not what people are going to be voting
on in the next week and that kind of has
baffled me through this whole campaign
season
so noon is pretty solid I I don't know a
ton about the guy but that's that's the
truth people don't care about this
election nonsense what we want are safe
and secure elections and we want
officials in charge that are going to
make sure that say you have to have an
ID that you can't double vote that we're
going to have secure elections when it
comes to mail and ballots and you can't
actually see through the envelope and
see who people voted for which is
exactly what we had in California when I
voted there last year but Chuck Todd I
mean he should just put just put on I
get it it's Meet the Press just put
under your name and Democrat operative
just put it on I like Democrats I'm
Chuck Todd I dig Democrat stuff and then
the show would feel a little bit more
honest right of course it would but but
this is this is what they're going to
keep running with and by the way after
the Red Wave next week one week from
today trust me you are going to be
allowed to question elections again and
trust me they will unleash violence on
the streets again when they feel it's
appropriate when they need to turn that
knob so you think about things a little
bit differently to rile up the bay face
again they're telling us already let's
not forget Hillary Clinton a few days
ago and then hit Chelsea Clinton on The
View two days ago what did she say she
has literally evidence that the
far-right mega Republicans are planning
on stealing the election it's odd she
didn't show the evidence why do I keep
printing out all this paper we have all
this paper here we're always printing
things Hillary didn't bring the paper
very odd